مع اقتراب معارك الاستنزاف شرق اوكرانيا
من ذروتها يتحول الانتباه مشاهدينا مره
اخرى الى هجوم الربيع المضاد الذي تخطط له
كياف احدى الجبهات المحتمله لهذا الهجوم
هي الجبهه الجنوبيه وتحديدا خرسون وايضا
زابوريا اي هجوم منهما سيعرض شبه جزيره
القرم للخطر ويعزلها عن باقي الاراضي
المتصله بها والخاضعه بطبيعه الحال
للسيطره الروسيه هذه الجبهه ولكونها منطقه
مسطحه ستكون اكثر ملائمه للدبابات
والمدفعيه الاوكرانيه ومن المرجح ان يتم
تعزيز الجبهه بالدبابات الغربيه وعربات
المشاه القتاليه مراقبون يرون ان اي تقدم
اوكراني من زابوريتا باتجاه ميلوتوبوبول
سيكون الانسب لاوكرانيا لانه سيقسم القوات
الروسيه الى قسمين جزء في شبه جزيره القرم
وايضا جزء في الشريط الشرقي من اوكرانيا
كما نشاهد وفي هذه الحاله سيكون لدى
القوات الروسيه في القرم خط امداد وحيد
وهو عبر الجسر الرابط بين روسيا وشبه
الجزيره وقد تنقطع الخطوط اذا ما تم
استهداف هذا الجسر مجددا روسيا تراقب
الوضع عن كثب واشاره اشاره فعليا تقارير
اعلاميه روسيه الى انكياف حشدت حوالي 75
الف جندي على جبهه زابوريا تقرير اخر
لنيوزوي قال ان تركيز متزايد للمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه على جبهه الشرقيه مع استعداد
اوكرانيا للهجوم المضاد في حين يسود
اعتقاد بان اوكرانيا ستشون هجوما مضادا في
الربيع قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ان
بلاده ستشن الهجوم فقط عندما تكون جاهزه
لذلك وزير الدفاع الامريكي تحدث عن هذه
الهجمات المضاده واكد ان هناك فرصه جيده
للغايه لنجاحها مضيفا انه على الارجح
ستكون لاوكرانيا اليد العليا ضد القوات
الروسيه خلال الاشهر المقبله